alors n'y couperai page sur les amours
ont fait un interview funérailles
nationales
c'était un petit peu difficile pour vous
puisque vous êtes mort donc dit moore
commence alors bah je suis mort de
vieillesse
ouais vous l'avez trouvé comment le
discours de chirac à l'enterrement au un
peu tremblotante
et quand l'équipe de la star academy a
chanté emmenez moi ça vous a ému
oui je crois surtout que c'était la
nouvelle équipe les anciens n'étaient
pas venus j'avais des béquilles vous
aimeriez qu'on dise pas de vous
maintenant que vous êtes mort charles
aznavour pas qu'on dit du bien
ouais ouais mais du bien bien pour
n'importe quoi
combes de grandissement vous grandit
tous avec vos ventes de disques sont
repartis c'est énorme depuis que vous
êtes mort vous avez revu mes arrières
petits-enfants étaient 120 chats est ce
qu'il ya des oeuvres posthumes des trucs
que vous avez jamais publiées et en
vivant et qui vont ressortir maintenant
comme les beatles
ah oui oui j'ai laissé ma voix sur des
bombes électroniques nouvelle
ouais et ils ajouteront lors qu'est ce
qu'ils voudront ajouter de sucre ça
génial
est ce que vous savez qu'on va
rebaptiser rue aznavour la rue sarah
that
ah oui oui ça c'est de la noël qui est
toujours maire de paris qui était sarah
that je sais pas un violoniste bagnols
alain grand violoniste est stable je me
suis renseigné quand même si le dire pas
simplement fikiel nom et d'y assister en
vip pour le reste non je me suis
renseigné
c'était quoi me dernier mot avant de
mourir charles aznavour je reviendrai à
bravo
à
alors charles aznavour quelques mails
les gens savaient évidemment que vous
seriez là ce soir ils ont envoyé des
mails sur le site france2 qui s'inscrit
en bas de l'écran
vincent torres de toulouse dites-moi
chose à vous vous avez fait fogiel
drucker en aparté la star ac
il se vend pas votre album ou quoi non
on l'a fait pour que ça se vende ouais
mais chez ca d'accord nicole guibon et
de boulogne billancourt
est ce que vous pensez qu'avec la
canicule l'été dernier vous avez perdu
une grande partie de votre clientèle
non je le crois pas je l'avais déjà
renouvelé
j'aime qu'on fait ça bien stéphane
gonzalez de strasbourg vous avez reçu en
1974 le prix de l'artiste pop le mieux
habillé
pourquoi ne pas vous être changé depuis
là vous avez un peu stoppé
je dirais simplement que une fois qu'on
l'a dit plus d'importance à la fois un
mail d'hervé bottineau de bron savez
vous qu'il existe un remake d'un taxi
pour tobrouk qui s'appelle un taxi pour
que bruce willis
le bouquet
les avants il est publié chez flammarion
ah oui et bruyant très brillant mais un
jour tu as raison l'abandon c'est comme
ça vous revenez quand vous voulez même
si vous n'avez pas de disque ou de
livres à vendre pourrait revenir but
vint courage et pas toujours quelque
chose à 20 quand vous voulez voilà je
montre une autre carte bancaire elle s'y
est amusante aussi tiré de la même
couleur mais lui autre chose car des
alcooliques anonymes avaient co ferry
des cons mieux vaut être super con que
rien du tout il s'appelait imagine que
vous êtes beaucoup non on n'est pas
nombreux nommer jan ya marcel jullian il
ya jean reno et les organes mais on
n'est pas nombreux ils voient pas on n'a
pas une chanson les pagnes centaines
d'ong a écrit charles aznavour
l'arménien de visite
voilà et là avec la carte de bons
clients tout le monde en parle vous êtes
reçu partout dans le monde entier ah
c'est vous monsieur aznavour